I think what we have here in Hollywood
is high art
it's party
[Applause]
party anywhere in the whole world where
would you go
I always wanted to be part of something
bigger yes let's go
something that lasts that means
something
you know when I first moved yeah
you know what shines on all the doors
read no actors or dogs allowed
I changed that good morning good job for
you I'll do anything that's the
[ __ ] they said to screw us
[Applause]
this [ __ ] is stealing the scene right
from under me icing her nipples but they
perk up through her dress I ain't ice in
my nipples this is natural
what do you say we come in for my
close-up now
what are your thoughts for the future
shouldn't stand in the way of progress
here's the twist
the girl seems nice she is she has no
idea what's next
there's some nuancy building you know
people care about malls
I've never done nothing except
disappoint people my whole life
I made it on my terms not theirs
[Music]
we are going to be more than they ever
bargained for
do means something
and I'm going to bed
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]